if you have something like the cosh
curve
alright when we dissect this thing we
find that its dimensions are not quite
one dimensional like a line nor
two-dimensional like you know a normal
shape with area okay it's somewhere in
between this idea of taking an object
that's you know trying to straddle the
dimensions is this idea we're gonna
further push on today okay
it's a this idea that you know see how
I've got a line right and a lion has how
many dimensions again combined oh why
just has one dimension right now what
you curl it up in this way it kind of
gets the shape that you end up getting
has more than one dimension but not
quite - okay
this idea that mathematicians were
trying to explore was could you twist
and turn a line such that it did get all
the way to being 2-dimensional a wine
can we twist the tenet in such a way
that you get a two-dimensional shape out
of it okay now because the idea is to
take a line and in order to be properly
two-dimensional it's got to visit all
the different spaces in our plane it's
got to get to every single one it's
going to fill up that space
so therefore the header you can make
this thing there are mathematicians were
tried to explore was called a space
filling
so even though it's the idea of a wine
like straight lines you can see little
intervals all join together
mathematicians call this a curve because
as you'll see what we're gonna get it
does bend and twist and curve around and
try to fill up this space okay so we're
gonna have a look at a series of space
skinny coasts
all right so the first one the first one
that everybody's called the piano curve
now demonstrate this here is the the
basic premise of the problem and here's
where your rule will come in if you've
got colors that will also be useful my
friend step the idea is to say all right
if I have an area of plain right
something like say D I could divide up
this plane into different parts right I
can subdivide down we're doing something
like this yesterday where we're trying
to measure the dimensions of something
right now what kind of curve could I
draw that would be able to visit all the
different parts of the plane right now I
can do this in a variety of ways okay so
piano sorry this shouldn't be to you
about you should
so I've got a 3x3 grid how do I visit
every single spot on this 3 by 3 P ok
this guy piano he said ok he's away he's
a scheme I can think of right different
color if I start in the bottom and I
want to go in a logical way so I don't
miss any points because remember what
I'm trying to do is get to I want to
fill up the entire space in theory I
want to get to every single point in the
plan how about I start down here guess
I'll just draw another point to indicate
a stop way and then I'll go through this
kind of the way but I am literally go
through shopping aisles well I but
Willie's right I go down one aisle okay
and then I kind of turn around and then
I just go down the next aisle right and
then I just turn around and then I go
down the next stop and that's where I
finish so you can see I divided up the
plane into nine places right and I
visited every single one I've been
pretty logical about it I haven't missed
them okay does that make sense so this
is one way of mapping out all these
different one two three four five six
seven nine a spot on the code spots of
the plan but you can see obviously I've
kind of missed the water spots right so
this is why we're looking at this under
fractal I can take this curve and I can
make it exhibit scale symmetry by just
subdividing smaller okay so watch this
draw another grid for me again we'll
make it three by three
okay but now what I want to do is I want
to be more detailed
here's where the fractal element of this
comes in okay I want to imagine it like
scale symmetry yeah
sickness little square down here this
little square is just like the whole
square that I started with just smaller
right do you agree with that it's just
another version I've just you know
zoomed out and so it looks smaller so
there's no reason why I can't for
instance
treat this one square just like I
treated the entire space here
I could subdivide this as a 3x3 square
okay I would start down young okay and
then I would just go through the aisles
all right you can see what I've done is
I have visited more points in this
little first square then this one has
right you can see I visited more parts
of the plane okay but now I've got all
these rest to go through well I'm going
to go through them in exactly the same
order that I went through here in fact
if you go back to your first if I go
through my first three by three grid
right you can see I've got two a descend
order right I started here one two three
over here and then I went seven eight
nine okay so I've done that one two
three four five six seven like in here
right but that's really just what so now
I'm going to go up to the next one then
I got two here okay so you can see in
fact I'm gonna take all of my nine
squares and I'm gonna divide that it to
nine right so let's divide them all but
let's do this
okay remember what I'm trying to do is
I'm trying to visit every spot in the
plane right every single point every
zero dimensional space right so I'm here
right I've done one little square and I
wish you to use a different color to
indicate now one of these piano curves
up and down the aisles one of them is
finished
now I'm gonna go up into here and I'm
going to start another piano curve you
see this scales to the tree right so
that means I go yeah up the aisles cross
down the aisles cross up the aisles it's
another piano curve because I started in
a different corner from where I started
before the orientation is different
you see it's flipped over okay but it's
still a pewter curve
it's just twist around a little
differently right
again this is our number two square
number two and I visited far more points
in this square than my original one do
okay I'm gonna go now up to here right
one two three so I'm gonna chuck another
piano curve here's my blue transition
light right and then a new curve begins
like so you can start to see where this
is going now right I write one two three
that's all the way up one aisle now I
need to cross it to the next I'll only
eat up right so I'm starting up in this
corner there's my little break and I
just start a new curve okay so down up
down okay I'm gonna stop talking through
each individual one now and I'm just
going to finish the piano curve because
you can kind of see what I'm doing I'm
gonna follow my original pot one two
three four five six seven eight nine but
each time for each square I'm putting in
a hole of upn okay okay so let's try it